I've hopefully given you a bit
of a gut feeling behind where
the formula of Gibbs Free
Energy comes from.
In this video I want to do
something a little bit more
rigorous and actually,
I guess you could
say derive the formula.
So to do that, let's just study
two systems that have
the exact same change
in entropy.
To depict that, I'll get out
our handy PV diagram.
What we're going to do is we're
going to compare two
systems. One that's this
perfect, reversible system and
one that's irreversible or
a spontaneous system.
So they're both going
to start here.
They're going to go from this
point on the PV diagram to
this point right here.
And before we go into exactly
what they're doing, I think
it's a good review to kind
of talk about what an
irreversible process and
what a reversible
process really is.
An irreversible process is this
theoretical thing where
you have no friction, where
you're always so close to
equilibrium that you can
always go backwards.
You're always-- you can kind of
view that the reaction is
never really proceeding
forward or backwards.
Although obviously it is moving,
so it's a very-- it
actually doesn't really exist
in nature, but it's a useful
theoretical construct.
So let me draw a little.
So if this is a-- I'll get
the good old pistons out.
So let's say this is an--
I'll do it twice.
So that's my irreversible
piston-- That'll be my
reversible, this is going
to be my irreversible.
Let me draw them.
OK, and let me label them.
So this right here is going
to be reversible.
And this right here is going
to be irreversible.
Or it could also be considered
spontaneous.
Using the key word.
That's going to matter for
Gibbs Free Energy.
But all spontaneous reactions
are irreversible.
So they're going to go from
this state to this state.
So in our reversible
world, we have this
little cap to our piston.
And we have our gas in here,
exerting some pressure.
And what we'd have is
a bunch of pebbles.
We have a bunch of
pebbles out here.
And we slowly remove the
pebbles one by one.
And as we remove the pebbles,
our piston-- or this movable
ceiling up here-- will
move upwards.
It'll move upwards.
So the pressure will push up,
but as we move up, we will
have lower and lower pressure
because the gases will bounce
into the surface less.
And we'll have a higher,
higher volume.
So as we move each
infinitesimally small grain of
sand, and we're going to do it
super slow, that we're always
infinitely close
to equilibrium.
We're going to move from this
state to this state.
And even better, let's view that
this is the first stage
of our Carnot cycle.
Let's say in either case, we're
on top of a reservoir.
So in either case, both of these
systems are on top of
this infinite reservoir that
has a temperature T1.
And what that does it keeps
the temperature constant.
So we're going to travel
along an isotherm.
Because normally if we were to
remove these things and if we
just allowed it to occur
adiabatically, we would
actually lose temperature.
We would actually lose
average kinetic
energy as work is done.
But in this case we have
this reservoir.
So heat is just going to be
transferred to my system.
Heat is going to
be transferred.
So let me call that QR.
Right?
If the reservoir wasn't here,
our temperature would go down.
But since we do have the
reservoir, we will constantly
be transferring heat.
And we've seen this.
This is just the first phase
of the Carnot cycle.
We'll move along an isotherm
like this.
This is the reversible case.
And the only reason why we can
even draw the state at every
point here is because reversible
processes are
quasistatic.
They're always infinitely
close to equilibrium.
And when we say reversible,
we're also saying there's no
friction between this little
piston in the cylinder.
That if we put a grain of sand
back, it'll go exactly to
where it was before.
And no energy was lost
because there was no
heat of friction there.
So this is what the graph
of the reversible
process would look like.
Now what does the graph of the
error irreversible-- Well,
actually no.
I won't draw the graph, but
let's talk about what the
irreversible process is
going to be like.
So it's going to look similar.
It's going to look like that.
It's going to have
its gases there.
But for the sake of an argument,
to get from that
state to that state, instead of
moving the pebbles one by
one, let's say I have
these big blocks.
And when I remove one of these
big blocks, I go from that
state to that state.
But obviously all hell
breaks loose.
So I'm not really defined in
this in between state.
But I definitely go from that
state to that state once I go
back to equilibrium.
Now the other key thing in the
irreversible process-- and
every real process in our world
is irreversible-- is
that you're going to
have friction here.
As this moves up, it's going to
rub against the side of the
container and generate
heat of friction.
So let me call that
So let me ask you a question.
If, in this case, Q sub R had
to be added to the system to
maintain its temperature, what's
going to be the Q sub
irreversible here?
How much has to be added to this
system in order to keep
it at the constant
temperature T1?
Will it have to be more or less
than what was added to
the reversible system?
Well this guy, as this piston
moves up, he's generating some
of his own heat.
So if this was an adiabatic
process, he wouldn't lose as
much temperature as
this guy would.
So he's going to need less heat
from the reservoir in
order to maintain
his temperature.
At T1.
In order to get to this
point on the isotherm.
Remember, this irreversible
process, we don't know what
happens over here.
He might be travelling
on some crazy path.
In fact, we can't even define
the path, because it goes out
of equilibrium.
So it's going to be
some crazy thing.
But we know it pops back on the
PV diagram right there.
But because it's generating some
of its own heat from the
friction, it's going to need
less heat from the reservoir.
So let me write that down.
The heat absorbed by the
reversible process is going to
be greater than the heat
absorbed by the
irreversible process.
And that's because the
irreversible process is
generating friction.
Fair enough.
Now what is the change in
entropy for both systems?
Well they both started here.
And they both ended here.
And entropy is a
state variable.
So the change in entropy for
the reversible process is
going to be equal to the change
in entropy for the
irreversible process.
They're both going from
there to there.
And obviously the entropy
has changed.
We're going from one state
to another state.
And the entropy, well I won't
go too much into it.
But let's ask another
question.
What is the total change in
entropy of the universe for
the reversible process?
So for the universe, that's
going to be-- Our universe
here is the reservoir
in our system.
So let me write here.
Reversible.
I don't want to run
out of space.
Let me see, I'll do it
in a different color.
So this is the reversible
process.
So the change in entropy of the
universe is equal to the
change in entropy of our
reversible process plus the
change in entropy of-- oh, I
already used R for reversible,
so let's call it the reserv--
well, the first three letters
are the same, so let me call
it of our environment.
Right?
And then the reversible process,
the change in entropy
of our reversible process is
the heat added for our
reversible process.
And we can use this definition
because it is
a reversible process.
It's that over T1.
And then what's the change in
entropy of our environment?
Well it's giving away Q sub R.
Right?
So its heat absorbed
is minus Q sub R.
And, of course, it's at a
constant temperature.
It is a heat reservoir.
It's at T1.
So it equals 0.
It equals 0.
Interesting.
So actually I should take
a little side note here.
That, the change in entropy of
the universe for a reversible
process is 0.
And actually that should make
a lot of intuitive sense
because the whole point of a
reversal process is you could
go in this direction, or you
could go in that direction.
It's always so close people to
equilibrium you can move in
either direction.
And if the entropy was greater
than 0 in one direction, it
would have to be less than
0 on the other direction.
So it wouldn't be able to go in
the other direction by the
second law of thermodynamics.
So it actually makes sense
that the entropy of the
universe-- the change in entropy
of the universe, not
just of the system--
when a reversible
process occurs, is 0.
Let's see if we can relate
that to the irreversible
process So if I wanted to
figure out the change in
entropy of the irreversible
process-- What's the change in
process?
And then let me subtract from
that the heat that was taken
away from the reservoir, from
the irreversible process, Q
sub IR, and of course
all this over T1.
What is this going to be equal
to in relation to 0?
Remember this is an
irreversible, spontaneous process.
Well, this value, the
irreversible process is
starting here and going there.
So its change in delta S is the
exact same thing as that.
Change in delta S is the same
as the reversible process.
So these two things
are equivalent.
Now, I just told you that since
there's some heat of
friction, this guy has to take
in less heat from the
reservoir than this guy.
So if this-- and I
wrote it here.
I mean, let me clean this
thing up a little bit.
I wrote it right here.
Q sub IR, the heat that the
irreversible process has to
take from the reservoir, because
generating its own
heat from friction, is less
than the heat from the
reversal process.
So this number, right here, is
less than this number here.
Or you could view it this way.
This number here was
equal to this.
So this number here is going
to be less than this.
So this has to be greater than
0 for the irreversible,
spontaneous process.
Now let's just do a little
bit of mathematics.
So this is the heat that was
essentially given to the
irreversible system.
It's a minus here because
this is the term.
It's kind of taken away from
the actual reservoir.
So let's just do a little bit
of-- let's just multiply all
sides of this equation by T1.
And we get T1 times delta S of
the irreversible process minus
Q of the irreversible process
is greater than 0.
Now, well, let's just--
So what is this?
How can we say this?
But let's actually just multiply
both sides of this by
negative 1.
And remember, this
is true for any
irreversible, spontaneous process.
If you multiply both
sides of this by
negative 1, you get this.
The heat added to the
irreversible process minus T
times delta S of the
irreversible process is going
to be less than 0.
This is true for any
irreversible, spontaneous process.
And at this point,
this should look
reasonably familiar to you.
When we wrote the Gibbs Free
Energy formula, we said change
in G is equal to delta H
minus T times delta S.
And we said that if this is less
than 0, then we have a
spontaneous process.
And this all makes sense.
Because these two are equivalent
to each other.
What's the only difference
here?
Here we wrote heat added
to the system.
Here we wrote change
in enthalpy.
And I've done three or four
videos right now, where I say
that change in enthalpy is equal
to the heat added to a
system, as long as we're
dealing with a constant
pressure system.
So we get this result just by
comparing a irreversible to a
reversible system.
And this is true for all
irreversible, spontaneous processes.
And then if we assume that we're
dealing with a constant
pressure system-- so you can
forget a little bit of what I
just drew, because we know
that this is true, and we
assume constant pressure--
then we get to this.
And then we know that if
something is spontaneous, then
this right here must
be less than 0.
So hopefully you found that
a little bit interesting.
Actually I'll do one
more point here.
This kind of gels with the
idea that second law of
thermodynamics tells us that for
any spontaneous process,
delta S is going to be greater
than or equal-- or well for
any spontaneous process, is
going to be greater than 0.
Because although this right
here isn't the formal
definition of entropy, because
we're not dealing with a
reversible process here,
you can kind of
think of it that way.
And so, at least, on an
intuitive level it gets you
there, that we have delta
S greater than 0.
And I won't fixate on that too
much, because what I did
earlier in the video is more
rigorous than what I'm heading
to right now.
So hopefully that gives you a
sense of where you can get to
the Gibbs Free Energy formula,
and how it drives spontaneous
reactions from just our basic
understanding of what
reversible and irreversible
processes are, and how they
relate to entropy and heat
exchange and enthalpy.